i don't think i'll
ever set foot on an oscar's red carpet
or have anything to do with uh any
nominations but
there is jackass got snubbed i'll tell
you every year for at least the
soundtrack
right um it was a bad grandpa was a
jackass film and they got nominated for
i think best makeup maybe oh really yeah
that makes sense
yeah it makes sense and they they didn't
win it i don't think
but um but yeah i always had it in my
mind that like if if i did win an
oscar i'd be the first person
on the stage to drop his drawers and
shove it up
my butt oh my god you would too
you would too that's funny and and
and i don't uh but part of me has this
thing like uh
you know they like all of my uh my
comedy and stuff
like is is now like sort of tracking my
experience in life and thus
like here i'm in my 40s having a midlife
crisis and as i
as i look towards putting together my
next show it's like oh
now i got to like actually go to like
the doctor for like the colonoscopy kind
of things that we do when
you know when when we get old and uh
you know instead of voluntarily shoving
things up your ass yeah right and so
for me there's so much comedy there
because like
you know guys can get in their 40s and
then now they've got to go to the doctor
and get like a finger up their butt like
you know
no guy wants that and then i'm going to
be the only dude
to ask the doctor like hey like like
how much can i fit up there you know
like like
are we talking an oscar you know because
i'll settle for going over to somebody's
place who has won an oscar
nobody's going to let you do that maybe
it's one they're not proud
of i know i mean yeah for editing or
something like juicy j
from three six mafia i think i got a
fighting chance
of letting him like getting him to let
me borrow his oscar
you borrow your oscar
i don't know i mean maybe i love that
that we're here the talk is of the
academy awards
and it's straight to sticking the oscars
like we didn't even really
have a segue to that it was just like oh
yeah that's what i want to do with one
yeah i mean you've been wanting to do
that for a while and you did do that on
hollywood boulevard
i did it with a uh like one of the toy
ones hey can you open up the door just
for some air
um yeah they have like the uh the
souvenir store where you buy a little
toy plastic oscar yeah and i did try it
and i like i wasn't getting any of them
more past the head those shoulders are
tough
and that was like a miniature one the
real awesome so that's why i gotta ask
the doctor at the colonoscopy
like like how much training like how
much like uh
can i how much training do i get i
already know i already know it's gonna
go like i'm gonna be like
how much extra is it really dangerous
are there concerns for me if i'm going
to work
out and stretch to try to fit more and
the doctor's probably going to be like
you out of your mind
and so i'll go get a second opinion from
like a gay porn guy
which is really good really mapped this
out yeah this is what i did
i don't even know about this and so he's
just doing all this he's not yeah but
he's
really had this all planned a long time
how long have you been thinking about
this well i mean the
the whole the next tour after this one
i'm thinking it's called
stevo's gone too far tour and like to
try and prolapse your butt
and put you know like but when did you
start
like what was the idea process for this
like where were you
what were you doing i don't i don't know
it's pretty straightforward i think you
know
you don't really have to question the
mindset i think we all know where it
comes from
i love tony hawk and he's raising money
to build skate parks by selling a
limited number of these
hand signed legendary photos
and there's a link in the bio to get one
so help
tony hawk build skateparks okay
buy a hand signed freaking
prince yeah dude
yeah dude